welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host definition
yes i do look like this sorry it's so
disappointing
now the wonder woman 1984 trailer has
just dropped a dc fandom
i was gonna live stream the event but
unfortunately due to technical issues
i've had to stop but i thought you know
what i'll react to the trailers anyway
and break them down just in case there's
anything you missed
now we're going to be going through this
trailer with a fine-tooth comb and
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here
screenings for the film have happened as
it was filmed years and years and years
ago
so if you don't want anything ruined
then i recommend that you turn off now
we're not going to be spoiling the
ending
just the things that are in this trailer
and the beginning of the movie but yeah
this is your last chance to check out
you're still here thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
[Applause]
this world is not yet ready okay so
we're starting to mascara this is
obviously just after
a young diana has been told that she can
train obviously
you know she was a kid throughout the
first film for for a large part of it
and her mother worried that if she
trained she would get older but this was
accepted and she started doing it i'm
guessing that was seen as fleshed out
here
and it's a really nice montage of a
young diana getting sort of
cut between an older one running along
it's it's really well shot i think
for all that you will do
your time will come diana
and the the thing with demascara is we
don't see that much of it but whenever
we do it's really interesting i kind of
class it as the wakanda
of dc and every time that pops up you
know it's
it's a totally alien civilization in the
first film
diana obviously went to earth and was a
fish out of water and this is very much
reflected in this film with steve trevor
being brought back to life in a time
period that he's not released to
we'll discuss that more as we get into
the trailer but yeah just something to
bear in mind
everything will be different
now it does look like she's swinging on
lightning there personally though i
think it's
the invisible jet now there's one of two
things that you can take from this
either they've decided to make the
invisible jet a real thing which i think
it should be because
it's such a big part of wonder woman law
or zeus is throwing lightning bolts
either way happy with which either one
it is but yeah
bear that in mind
okay so she does swing from one
lightning bolt to the other so yeah
it might not be the invisible jet unless
the invisible jet shoots lightning bolt
might not be zeus either as he's sort of
been absent from the dc
universe but it is strange that she's
got this power and it's only been
referenced now
in a film that's set in the past leave
your theories below on what you think it
could be
citizens of the world i'm here to change
your life
anything you want
okay so this is maxwell lorde um
according to the leaks what happens
is he basically recruits qui kristen
wig's character
barbara minerva to find a magic stone
for him that grants wishes
now kristen wiig takes his stone and
wishes to become a superhero because she
sort of
developed an obsession for wonder woman
i don't know if that's true but that's
just what
they like say um and from then what
happens is
she gets more and more powerful and
starts transforming into cheetah
now during this time maxwell lord's got
the stone he
he gets granted all these wishes he
becomes a very high-ranking politician
he starts offering it to other people
almost as a bribery
but barbara minova starts coming after
him he wants to stop her so what he does
is that he makes a promise to wonder
woman that
if if she if she managed to take down
cheat
then she can have whatever wish she
wants wonder woman say
i don't really believe you i need some
proof so what he does is resurrect steve
trevor
and that's kind of how the character is
brought back according to the leaks
again
don't know if it's 100 true but it does
make a lot of sense from from what we've
seen so far basically
anything you dream of you can have it
so i'm guessing that steve has sort of
just
been completely taken from his death
into this time and he doesn't really
have a full awareness of what's going on
at this point
diana lucky you it's like now one day
has passed
i don't want to be like anyone i want to
be
so yeah that's basically what kristen
wiig's character
wishes for i don't know why i keep
calling that barbara minerva
she wants to be an apex predator she's
sick of sort of being stepped on by
society
she's basically the joker we live in a
society and she's bloody sick of it
so she wishes to become an apex predator
which gradually transforms her into
cheetah
you've always had everything well people
like me have
now it is interesting that that was set
in washington there i'm guessing that's
something to do with maxwell lord
becoming the president potentially
they have said that he's going to be a
very donald trump like figure and sort
of parodying that so
you know it did sort of show at the
start that when he was on the podium
that
it did look to me like he was in front
of the white house again i'm british so
i'm not sure if they do that with
everything in america or if it's just
the president but
you know it did look like the president
sorry for being an idiot
well people like me have had nothing so
obviously
kristen wiig's an archaeologist diana is
as well and we did see that fleshed out
quite a bit in
justice league when she was working on
the statue and this is kind of how they
meet before everything kicks off
and here's um diana fighting in the
white house
so yeah maxwell lord is probably
president captain obvious
well here it's my turn
get used to it i like how she's got a
cheater skin
coat nice nice little touch there
i've never been one for rules the answer
is always more
so there we can see maxwell lord working
with barbara minerva so i'm guessing
that's kind of how it all ties together
now that did look like a turbine engine
on the invisible jet
i don't know if i'm missing that but
yeah maybe
but yeah it looks like a turbine engine
now
the way i fly they will never find us i
forgot to tell you
what radar will they will they shoot at
us
so what i really like about this is that
in the first wonder woman film
wonder woman was a fish out of water she
was going to society
and you know she was saying oh my god
what says i scream it's bloody great i
love that that's a line from the script
they've kind of reversed it here um
diana has gotten used to what society's
like because she's lived in
it for so long whereas steve trevor he's
been
dead for a long time and he's gonna be
the fish out of water in this one which
i really appreciate and i think that's a
good little twist on it
and there we can see maxwell lord
at the white house podium before so it
looks like he is the president
and he's doing magic with his hand maybe
he wished for magic powers too
and there's our first look at cheetah
not 100 on the cgi
there they still have time to well
they've had two years to work on this
movie so i'm guessing that's as far as
it goes but yeah
nice little nice little look
barbara what did you do
so maybe she even got the stone back and
made further wishes that kind of
developed her further and that's why she
gets the big transformation
but either way it looks like this is
going to be the big showdown and i i
really do
think that wonder woman versus cheetah
is a good fight to have
ares wasn't so hot on him as a villain
but i think cheater
is really in line with wonder woman and
who knows this might open the door for
suicide squad appearances down the line
there's a lot of things that you can do
with chia so i definitely appreciate it
damn
okay so this looks like it's a flip on
the scene in the original film in which
diana got ready
i think we can do better nice
does everybody parachute now only in
theaters as well
doesn't have a release date so we don't
know if it's been delayed yet
word is that they're going to wait to
see how 10 it does and then decide
whether to release it or not
but from that first look really really
enjoyed it
only in theaters as well means it's not
going to um video on demand
but yeah that's pretty much the trailer
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts so
leave them below in the comments so i
know what you think
um if you enjoyed this video then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
first look at the bat symbol
and just our general thoughts on the
robin leak and loads of other batman
stuff which is going to be linked at the
end
make sure you stick around because i'm
doing more streams like this later on
all the other trailers and hopefully i
see you soon
take care peace
you